it's official zombies 2 is coming to a
screen near you
but will stars McDonald II and my load
Manheim be reprising their roles we sure
hope so because well we couldn't imagine
the sequel without them keep watching to
find out everything there is to know
about zombies 2 you are watching history
unfold the announcement musical numbers
zombies cheerleaders and pets now that's
a recipe for success it's hard to
believe that it's already been a year
since the beloved Disney Channel movie
first aired and now we can officially
get excited about the highly anticipated
sequel according to Disney the original
zombies movie brought over 12 million
viewers to their channel during its
premiere and this high viewership
encouraged producers to take on the
sequel president and chief creative
officer Gary Marsh had this to say about
the franchise's first installment
zombies took our world audience of kids
and families by storm with its powerful
themes and incredible music so knowing
this we're not surprised that zombies 2
has just been confirmed on Monday
February 11th the network announced that
zombies 2 was it go and that production
would begin in spring of 2019 the first
zombies movie took about nine months to
film so if we're basing things on the
past zombies too should be released
sometime before the new year however an
official premiere date has yet to be
determined so we'll just have to wait
and see if the movie's production goes
as planned but since zombies was such a
big hit we'd be surprised if Disney
didn't make the sequel their top
priority progress we're making progress
returning cast in late November of 2018
Milo Manheim who plays the role of said
the zombie talked about how badly he
wanted a zombie sequel during this j14
interview Milo had this to say in my
opinion it would be dumb not to do it
it's such a great movie everyone loves
it and luckily for him his dream is
coming true
but when asked about a potential
plotline Milo confessed that he had no
idea how the network would pick up
zombies - and since the original movie
didn't end on a cliffhanger fans have no
idea what to expect but we have the
inside scoop so stick around until the
end to find out what zombies 2 will be
all about
so which actors will be
turning for the sequel so far it's been
revealed that Meg Donnelly and Milo will
be reprising their roles as Addison and
Zed but for now these are the only two
cast members who have been confirmed
although we can expect a handful of new
characters to make an appearance in
zombies - that doesn't mean that the
majority of the original cast will get
left behind after all zombies - wouldn't
be the same without Bucky and Eliza
we're played by Trevor Tordjman and
Kylie Russell respectively
and considering that both these Disney
Channel stars aren't working on too much
right now we're certain that they'd be
delighted to reprise their roles we're
super happy to find out that Milo and
Meg are returning to Seabrook high but
we're also thrilled to announce that
Paul Hoenn is also returning to the
scene Paul directed the first zombies
movie and helped it reach its full
potential so we can only expect good
things from this famous director but in
case you're not convinced you should
know that Paul is sort of a big deal
this is made obvious by the fact that
he's directed tons of Disney Channel
Original Movies in fact he's responsible
for camp Rock to the Final Jam jump in
and Eddie's million-dollar cook-off on
top of that David Light and Joseph Rizzo
will also be reprising their roles as
the sequels writers so you can expect
zombies to to hold a similar feel as the
original the plot Addyson and said our
star-crossed lovers who never once
thought that they'd end up together but
chemistry is a funny and visible thing
that we never see coming
Addison's father is the chief of the
Seabrooke zombie Patrol so Addison was
born and raised to fear zombies above
all else but funny enough she ended up
falling in love with one but before she
could get over her prejudice
Addison ended up punching said in the
face zombies might be a musical that
revolves around high school students and
pep rallies but there's so much more to
this movie than meets the eye knowing
this it's not too surprising to find out
that zombies was nominated for a
humanities prize
the musical drama is jam-packed with
wholesome themes that encourage the
population to love and accept everyone
so despite being a movie for preteens
and children zombies can teach everyone
a thing or two although see Burke I had
hard time welcoming zombies to their
school Addison and Ed's romance help
them see each other as equals
instead of rivals but according to
Disney a new threat will be facing the
high school comes aam be Stu so what can
we expect from zombies - well a new set
of songs and performances of course and
if they're anything like what we saw in
the first film we're in for a treat the
sequel will pretty much pick up where it
left off so yes expect to see Zed and
Addison walking hand-in-hand down the
halls of Seabrook I said the football
player and Addison the cheerleader are
still trying to unite their high school
but things are definitely looking up
so what happens when a group of
outsiders moves to Seabrook to attend
the unified high school well that's for
Disney to know and us to find out
according to Deadline werewolves will
populate the halls causing tensions to
arise within the school despite wanting
to see the good in everyone Addison and
said we'll have trouble coping with the
new students and the relationship is
rumored to take a big hit for the time
being we don't know if zombies and
werewolves - have any issues with each
other so it could be that said chooses
to exclude the group while Addison
attempts to integrate it and maybe
jealousy will flare up when Addison gets
a little too close to a new wolf on
campus we don't know about you but we
can hardly wait to see what the sequel
has in store for us so in the meantime
we're going to rewatch the original film
over and over again so there you have it
guys everything you know about zombies -
before you go make sure to let us know
which zombies song is your favorite in
the comments below and that's a wrap
what more videos like this one make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and we'll send
them your way thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]